[Música]
Hola Aquí comienza la crónica de medio
ambiente bienvenidos
abril es el mes de la tierra y por eso
queremos Resaltar algunas iniciativas
que existen en América Latina para
proteger nuestro planeta y comenzamos en
Uruguay que logró reemplazar los
combustibles fósiles por energías
limpias entre 2017 y 2021 el 94% de su
generación eléctrica fue de fuentes
renovables como el viento y el sol esto
lo posiciona como el segundo país del
mundo con mayor participación de
energías renovables de acuerdo con el
informe Ren 21 el camino que los llevó
hasta aquí comenzó en 2010 cuando los
distintos partidos políticos firmaron un
acuerdo para hacer de la transición
energética una política de estado a
largo plazo en la que las diferencias
ideológicas no interfirieran y este
acuerdo se convirtió en una de las
principales causas del éxito como nos
contó Gerardo amarilla el subsecretario
del Ministerio de ambiente de Uruguay
y finalmente primero tener políticas
serias a largo plazo que supongan la
seguridad de los privados de tener
estabilidad jurídica y seguridad
política y además de eso Este por
supuesto que esas políticas de estado de
la mano con la inversión privada que es
fundamental en este aspecto asegurando
el retorno a largo plazo creo que es un
proyecto de ganar ganar todos ganan
ganan los privados que hacen la
inversión y que recuperan su su recurso
a largo plazo pero también gana el
estado que tiene energía renovable y
gana la sociedad pues En definitiva no
contaminamos el ambiente
las alianzas público privadas y la
sociedad también fueron importantes en
uno de los fondos de agua más relevantes
de la región aguatica ayuda a proteger
la subcuencas de los ríos grande y
virilla en Costa Rica la particularidad
es que ambos nutren al que es el río más
contaminado de Centroamérica el grande
de tárcoles pero el trabajo de este
fondo ha ayudado a recuperar una buena
parte del agua para garantizarla en una
región donde se asienta el 60% de la
población del país Aquí el factor
determinante fue la ciencia como nos
explicó Manuel Guerrero secretario
técnico de agua tica
la base técnica científica con la que
cuenta guatica es tal vez lo más
importante porque nos permite
priorizar esas actividades y que
realmente esas actividades tengan un
impacto positivo sobre el recurso
hídrico entonces no es una ocurrencia de
Manuel Guerrero o no es una ocurrencia
del del de nuestra junta directiva que
quien se haga la reforestación en ese
sitio porque es él es bonito o porque es
sino porque de verdad va a tener un
impacto Entonces
el tener esa base técnica científica nos
asegura que vamos a tener un impacto a
futuro esto
creo que sería lo más importante
Buscar replicar en otras latitudes que
esa base técnica científica sea El Punto
de partida para poder lograr ese impacto
deseado
tiene múltiples proyectos con solo uno
de ellos han logrado restablecer
alrededor de 650.000 metros cúbicos de
agua al año lo que alcanza para más de
2.700 familias de cuatro miembros
teniendo en cuenta que el promedio de
consumo diario de una persona es 200
litros de agua según el instituto
costarricense de acueductos y
alcantarillados Manuel nos habla al
respecto nosotros tenemos proyectos que
hemos venido desarrollando con coca-cola
tnc uno de ellos es agua por el futuro
en el caso de Costa Rica se llama
reabastecimiento de agua la naturaleza y
lo que hacemos Es proteger áreas de
bosque hemos incorporado más de 607
hectáreas de de bosque en esquemas de
protección regeneración natural y
asistida y no solo se queda ahí sino que
transformamos o o traducimos esas
hectáreas de bosque en metros cúbicos de
agua reabastecidos con ese proyecto
hemos logrado reabastecer por año
alrededor de seiscientas treinta mil
seiscientos cincuenta mil metros cúbicos
de agua y sin duda los ciudadanos
también son fundamentales para proteger
el planeta y en Guatemala protección
pasa por los indígenas una parte de los
maya por ejemplo están asentados en
bosques y son los guardianes de estos
así lo explica Rosa Chávez una mujer
tanto de los pueblos quiché Como
cachiquel quien además es poeta y
activista en otras entrevistas ella ha
explicado que los defensores ambientales
son estratégicos para encontrar puntos
de confluencia y por eso ha trabajado
como coordinadora de programa en la
organización jazz que se dedica a
amplificar la voz de las mujeres y su
poder colectivo a Rosa le preocupan
Especialmente los indígenas y dice que
sus derechos han sido pisoteados
las mujeres indígenas somos
diversas y plurales hay distintas
experiencias dentro de nuestra misma
experiencia como mujeres indígenas
definitivamente las compañeras
defensoras de tierra y territorio que
están en primera línea en los
territorios afectando sus cuerpos sus
comunidades y sus familias directamente
siendo criminalizadas y judicializadas
son las que están sufriendo aún más
estas consecuencias siguen los pueblos
teniendo que hacer estas resistencias
históricas porque es el estado de la
mano con las extractivas quienes están
despojando a los territorios Entonces no
se tiene
un apoyo Estatal sino más bien tanto el
estado como sus aparatos de represión
están en la mano de las extractivas
Esto fue lo que le dijo Rosa a nuestra
corresponsal en Centroamérica Aurora así
llegamos al final de La Crónica si
ustedes quieren proponerme algún tema
ambiental Los invito a que me escriban a
mi cuenta de Twitter arroba María cl
Aguirre pueden ver esta y todas las
crónicas en France 24.com
[Música]